♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC) ♪
- (HORSE NICKERING)
- My beloved wife!
I've missed you terribly.
Thank you for returning
Lady Bolton safely.
Now, dismount and
kneel before me.
Surrender your army,
and proclaim me
the true Lord of Winterfell
and Warden of the North.
I will pardon you for deserting
the Night's Watch.
I will pardon these treasonous
Lords for betraying my house.
Come, bastard.
You don't have the men,
you don't have the horses,
and you don't have Winterfell.
Why lead those poor souls
into slaughter?
There's no need for a battle.
Get off your horse. Kneel.
I am a man of mercy.
You're right.
There's no need for a battle.
Thousands of men
don't need to die.
Only one of us.
Let's end this the old way.
You against me.
(CHUCKLES)
I keep hearing stories
about you, bastard.
The way people in the North
talk about you.
You're the greatest swordsman
who ever walked.
Maybe you are that good.
Maybe not.
I don't know if I'd beat you,
but I know that my army
would beat yours.
I have 6000 men. You have what?
Half that?
- Not even?
- Aye. You have the numbers.
Will your men want to fight
for you, when they hear
you wouldn't fight for them?
(CHUCKLES)
He's good. Very good.
Tell me. Will you let
your little brother die
because you're
too proud to surrender?
How do we know you have him?
(THUD)
(HORSE NEIGHING)
RAMSAY:
Now, if you want to say--
You're going to die tomorrow,
Lord Bolton.
Sleep well!
(HORSE GALLOPING)
She's a fine woman, your sister.
I look forward to having her
back in my bed.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC) ♪
And, you're all
fine-looking men.
My dogs are desperate
to meet you.
I haven't fed them for
seven days. They're ravenous.
I wonder which parts
they'll try first.
Your eyes...
Your balls!
We'll find out soon enough.
In the morning then, bastard.
- (CLIP CLOP OF HOOVES)
- (HORSES NICKERING)